how are you today sir
so good liz how are you good i imagine
you're excited to talk about this show
i'm i've been waiting to talk about this
for two
years the moment i got the job i was
ready to do press
and every and every step of the way like
in the writer's room i was like oh i
can't wait to talk about this
when we saw animatics oh i can't wait to
ev when we cast
everything we did i couldn't wait to
talk about and it was weird being
involved in a project where you couldn't
say anything
like i don't usually do that i make json
bob stuff i'll tell you about every
detail before the movie comes out and
stuff
but being involved in something where
it's just like no you can't mum's the
word you can't share any of this
it was tough for a blabber mouth like me
i got a show i do every week where i
talk about this kind of [ __ ] fat man
beyond
and still i had to like keep stunned the
whole time so this
i've been waiting for this moment for a
long time obviously excellent
well i've seen the first five episodes
and it's fascinating and
the thing i really i i want to know
first is
what was the pitch you went in with this
for this
the pitch was essentially my pitch the
title of the original title of it was
masters of the universe the end of the
universe so the pitch
pretty much what you've seen so far you
guys haven't seen
part two yet but it's it's very much
that story uh the idea i had was like
you know i looked at he-man
as superman i'm a big calmable guy and
stuff uh
he has a secret identity just like
superman clark kent to prince adam and
stuff
um but with a character like superman
and a character like he-man
you have the impossibly powerful
character so he-man is so strong he can
do like literally anything
and if if there's things he can't well
he has the sort of power
to take him the rest of the way for
heaven's sakes you know that
doesn't create a lot of compelling drama
if you're like well he's going to win
he's always going to win because he's
the most powerful man in the universe
and stuff so the idea was like all right
what happens if you remove superman from
metropolis
everybody depends on this cat he's the
epicenter of everybody's life
to me it was an interesting story to be
like all right let's pull this
element out and see how the world reacts
without them and so that was the story
that i pitched and
rob david at mattel television was like
i like this let's take it to netflix and
i was like we're going to pitch this to
netflix
and he was like netflix is doing it and
i was so delighted at that point cause
like i'd gone in to pitch so many things
at netflix
five six things prior to this and they'd
always been like oh you're the guy that
made mall rats we love you and they
never pick it up
so like when we went into netflix this
show was a done deal it wasn't even me
going like please you got to pick it up
they're like oh we're making this show
it's a question of whether you're going
to be involved
so then i pitched to teddy be a sally
there and he went for the story
in a big bad way and he was like you're
the guy let's go forward so
i got lucky man that they like the story
and every time i watch
the episodes and i've watched them in
every incarnation as animatics as fully
blown animation
uh scoreless with outscored temp
soundtrack without tempting track
um i i i have this like insanely
gratifying
feeling of like oh my god somebody gave
me something really important to handle
i'm
i'm not that guy nobody ever gives me
anything important i handle jay and son
and bob and they don't even want me to
do that
so to give me something that like is a
legacy franchise that people have known
for a long time
and they were like we think you're the
guy was honestly made me
rise to the occasion like and and teddy
was like such a wonderful boss like
um i've never had this experience where
a creative exec in charge of the project
is more creative than the people tasked
to create the project itself he loved
this stuff
so much as much as like all of us enjoy
he-man the master of the universe
this is teddy's religion since he was a
kid and he very seriously
said like after i pitched he was like i
love that he's going i think you're the
guy
this is what i'm going to tell you he's
gone when i was a kid i watched every
episode and i loved it
and i assumed that he-man would be
killed by skeletor i was so scared
he's gone then i grew up and realized
that was never gonna happen he's gone
all i
ask is that you give me those stakes
again you make me
afraid for these characters again the
way i felt when i was a kid and he said
but most importantly
i'm begging you don't make fun of this
he's going it's so easy because some of
the characters are goofy
to just lean into the comedy you know as
per the
the four non-blonde song that have been
on the internet for years
he's like no reference that don't make
jokes at their expense he's going like
this is a deep bench of of rich
intellectual property as deep a bench as
marvel or dc has
he's gone all i ask is that you treat
them like shakespeare
and i was like i i would love to attempt
that like
i can't write shakespeare good i could
do fake spear i could put like lofty
words in the mouths of
scenery chewing skeleton-faced arch
villains and stuff
so it was kind of like right up my alley
excellent
you know uh talk to me a little bit
about the voice casting just because
you know there's some really great
actors here and they're not doing stuff
you would necessarily assume
they would do i for example wouldn't
have thought of casting steven root as
battle cat
but now can you unsee it you know what
i'm saying like
i i went for root i root was one of my
suggestions where i was like can we go
for stephen root
um most people when they think about
casting battle cat
they think about battle cat but i think
about cringer
because most of the time you're going to
spend with the non
you know kind of uh heroic version of
battle cat
as cringer so steven's got this like
amazing
steven's an amazing actor period but
like he also has this very gentle voice
when you talk to him in real life
he he talks like this he's always like
oh yeah i mean
yeah i hope that's the case it's very
hopeful voice you know and he can play
some shitty characters and movies and tv
shows
but he's in real life he's got that
voice so i was like i think
stephen could totally be our cringer and
he came in and he gave us a bit of bert
lar
but he gave us most importantly soul
like one of my favorite monologues in
the entire thing is
when he's like do you remember who named
me cringer when he convinces tila
to go on the journey and you know i
don't know that anyone was gonna
nail that performance but but root so we
got
incredibly lucky with the cast i mean
i'm telling you like
you've seen a lot of the lena heady
performances evelyn
wait until you see part two like they
should give her an acting award for part
two if not part one
because she transcends like everybody
stepped up to the mic
and brought this incredible a game
nobody like whiffed it nobody was just
like what are we doing yeah
like everyone brought passion because a
lot of people
were familiar with masters as children
it was a part of their lives or in the
case of mark
mark was like i remember the year that i
had to personally call mattel
to try to track down a [ __ ] castle
grayskull for my kid so he's like i'm
well aware of skeletor in the masters
universe
and you had people joining for that
reason man so
it was bliss and we got huge names a lot
of cats i've worked with before
like diedrick i've worked with before
mark i've worked with before
chris wood who plays r prince adam and
he-man i've worked with before he was on
supergirl the episodes i've done
um jason muse is our stinker i think
i've worked with him somewhere in the
past
and so on there were definitely people i
worked with and then the rest was made
up of like people whose work i just
really dug
you know as a big game of thrones fan
like uh having
lena come in and having um liam come in
as well
because liam has that paternal voice his
sir davos was like the most
likable lovable character on that show
and so we were like that's the voice we
need for man at arms and we got lucky
with these people saying yeah
because as if people like the show
i i think it has a great deal to do with
those vocal performances man we're
getting
a list cast performances for you know
a cartoon that most people would not
really think twice about
in the real world they lent us their
credibility
so much so that when we made the
announcement like here's the cast people
like holy [ __ ]
like wow i want to hear what that is and
that even like lifted my credibility
you know people like hey [ __ ] good
for you it ain't just like [ __ ]
clerks all the time is it you're rubbing
elbows with the big stars and stuff
but um it became like one of my favorite
things i've ever done i put this side by
side with clerks at this point shoulder
to shoulder
i think honestly this is the one they'll
remember me for with clerks they'll be
like he made clerks and he got to play
with he-man once when i die
well i think something that speaks to
the quality of the voice performances
is how emotional the material is like i
was not expecting to be moved to tears
by orco
did you did you cry a little bit i will
cry
every time i watch it and i've seen that
in script form like it wasn't my idea
i've seen it in script form
i've seen an animatic form and i've seen
it fully fleshed out in animation then i
saw it with bear's score
doesn't matter it always makes me cry
because that is the heart of heroism
somebody who can't who's gonna try no
matter what
somebody somebody's gonna put their life
on the line for everyone else like you
know in the story we have this
fellowship
and orco is the weakest link as he's
always been
and in that moment he gets this
incredible glow up
to send him out for good you know that
was he was
he was somebody we were concerned about
when we sat down in the writer's room
because we're like
erko's the weak spot because a lot of
people hated orco but we're like
rather than get rid of him how do we
make people fall in love with him
and then get rid of them so that people
are like orco is my favorite what do you
mean he's
you know gone and so that that allowed
us to create some compelling drama but
the secret to orko
i swear to you is griffin newman griffin
who performs orco
he the the guy who performed orco in the
original show who was one of the
producers i think is lou shimer
um he would record his voice and then
they put it through a filter
to make it high-pitched and sound like
this griffin is not put through a filter
what you hear
is literally griffin just sitting there
gone like this and creating that orco
voice
which to me was so special because kids
can come up to him in the real world and
if somebody's like this is orco
he could literally be orco for them and
not have to be like well i have to put
on a filter on my voice
griffin gave us such an incredibly
soulful performance
and he sought that role like i saw him
on twitter
trying to get that role so much so that
he popped to the top of our list where
i'm like
you guys know this guy who's on the tick
he really wants to play
[ __ ] orco and he came in and blew us
all away and that performance like one
of my
favorite moments of anything i've ever
done is when he's facing down scareglow
and he goes like
it's okay tila like i could i get
[ __ ] emotional like
i'm not scared he's like he can't he
can't he goes i'm not afraid he can't
scare me
it sounds like the bravest little
five-year-old
facing the lord of hell and so oh my god
like
we if anybody went into this series
going man orco was always a drag
i guarantee you by the time they hit
that moment they're like you
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ] you killed the
best character
of course thank you so much for your
time it's been an absolute moment
pleasure thanks so much